bisschen themen sprung ja hama das nicht
da hat genau harter schnitt aber
trotzdem möchte ich immer so ein
bisschen in die überlegung kommen was
passiert eigentlich wenn es ein land
versäumt innovation zu fördern und
deutschland hat versäumt innovationen zu
fördern wir haben es verpasst moderne
grüne technologie zu setzen wenn es
darum geht um sich energie zu beschaffen
wir haben es einfach darauf verlassen
dass es billiges russisches öl weniges
russisches gas gibt dieser song sind
eine wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit
gebracht und diese abhängigkeit schränkt
jetzt unsere politische
handlungsfähigkeit an jetzt möchten wir
uns bitten mal den blick zu weiten und
dann sehen wir dass deutschland auch in
anderen bereichen innovations- schwach
ist hier drohen den anschluss in der
nicht nur in der grünen technologie
sondern auch in der automobilbranche und
in der finanzbranche verlieren nehme man
die automobilbranche als beispiel
jahrzehntelang war deutschland führend
innovationen gingen von deutschland in
die welt deutsche autos sind für ihre
qualität bekannt die letzten beiden
trends haben allerdings leider verpasst
und das war das autonome fahren und der
elektroantrieb
mit der folge dass die autopiloten die
software dafür jetzt in usa programmiert
wird die batterien aus china kommen ja
und ich frage sollen die
zukunftsweisenden fragen wie wir
arbeiten wie wir bezahlen wie wir
kommunizieren wie wir essen wie wir uns
fortbewegen letztlich wie wir leben
sollen die von anderen beantwortet
werden oder von uns und ich sage wir
müssen die beantworten und dafür müssen
wir zu alter innovationsstärke
zurückfinden wenn wir das nicht tun sehe
ich unseren wohlstand und unsere
freiheit in gefahr bravo
das war sehr gut vorgetragen ich habe
eine frage zu der innovationsstandort du
hast ja jeder ein start-up
mitgegründeten finn tech startup war so
schlecht der innovationsstandort
deutschland oder fehlen uns einfach die
kreativen köpfe also hat deutschland die
barrieren gesetzt wie soja unser
standort schlecht also uns fehlen der
standort ist deshalb schwierig weil
europa ganz zersplittert ist ja wir
müssen europaweit einheitlichen markt
sehen im moment haben wir einen
regulierungswut ja billy ist einen tick
unternehmen ja wir machen innovationen
im bereich wie man im internet zahlt ja
das ist auch wichtig finde ich dass wir
das in deutschland machen und nicht auf
chinesischen servern oder amerikanischen
servern aber
die denken wir haben ein binnenmarkt
aber es wird trotzdem in jedem land
jeder mitgliedsstaat hat seine eigenen
sondern locken und verhindert es
letztendlich dass das unternehmer
diesen diesen großen markt als einen
markt nutzen können ja sein dass und das
ist schon eine herausforderung noch mal
so finde ich dass wir auch dieses ganze
gründerteam überhaupt nicht als das
begreifen was es ist nämlich wichtig ist
wichtig für den standort dass wir
startups fördern dass wir innovation
hier haben wir sollten anschließend an
so die alten gründergeist den wir hatten
und und und das feiern und nicht immer
nur die digitalisierungs risiken sehen
wie man das doch häufig macht ja
interessant aber natürlich auch ein
demokratieproblem nicht also die
europäische integration die hängt
natürlich von den mitgliedsstaaten ab
und die haben sozusagen noch nationale
identitäten und interessen und rechts
vorstellungen die sie nicht so leicht
aufgeben und das geht ja wohl nur auf
einem demokratischen weg dass wir uns da
einigen und das heißt das dauert und ist
mühsam das ist sicher mühsamer als in
china trotzdem lebe ich lieber hier wo
sozusagen also vergleichsweise echte
demokratie herrscht und eben nicht in
einem autoritären in der autoritären
diktatur und ich meine dass das dilemma
zum beispiel bei der energieversorgung
es ist ja richtig also man überall
gleichzeitig aus der kohle und atomkraft
aussteigt dann hängt man erstmal über öl
und gas für atomkraft kriegen sie keine
gesellschaftliche mehrheit mehr hin
glaube ich obwohl das ja jetzt wieder
verschärfen diskutiert wird und dann ist
natürlich auch das zusätzliche problem
also was ist in schleswig holstein da
gibt es ja schon ganz schön viele
windkraftanlagen uns oder ist die
landschaft schon ganz schön gewaltig
verändert was es nicht gibt sind die
trassen weil die leute keine lust haben
die stromtrasse durch ihren garten zu
haben da kommt das klassische noch
einmal bergab phänomen finde ich auch
ärgerlich muss politik auch viel stärker
erklären diskutieren richtig in clinch
gehen mit den leuten aber es eben nicht
diktatorisch durchsetzen sondern es ist
eben es muss die leute müssen gewonnen
werden dafür soll auf gar keinen fall
die katholisch durchgesetzt werden ja
ich möchte das weder innovation hier
fördern weil es eben nicht dann
irgendwann nur produkte nutzen möchte
die in china gebaut werden unter einem
ganz anderen werte kamen ganz anderes
verständnis von datenschutz von
privatheit etc deshalb sage ich wir
müssen uns auch an große
infrastrukturprojekte ran trauen und
müssen die durchsetzen und nicht
irgendwie sagen irgendwie anders wird es
schon machen und wir können es an
beziehen innerhalb der europäischen
union können und sollten wir es machen
und sollten diesen großen markt auch
nutzen aber wir brauchen das schon eine
wirtschaftliche unabhängigkeit
damit wir uns eben nicht sagen bei uns
machen wir das alles nicht aber dann
nutzen wir dann doch die produkte auf
den autokraten